here is a passage from the Scottish
philosopher writer even a little bit of
mathematics historian Thomas Carlyle and
he wrote this in on heroes hero worship
and the heroic in history and this is in
reference to his view on Mohammed and
the spread of Islam a poor shepherd
people he's referring to the arabs
before muhammad roaming unnoticed in its
deserts since the creation of the world
a hero prophet was sent down to them
with a word they could believe see the
unnoticed becomes the world notable the
small has grown world great within one
century afterwards arabia is at granada
on this hand at delhi on that he's
speaking of within a hundred years of
Muhammad's death the Muslim Empire has
spread from what would eventually be
southern Spain all the way to northern
India these Arabs the man Muhammad and
that one century is it not as if a spark
had fallen one spark on a world of what
seemed black unnoticeable sand but lo
thus and proves explosive powder blazes
heaven high from Delhi to Granada I said
the great man was always as lightning
out of heaven the rest of men waited for
him like fuel and then they too would
flame and thomas carlyle is known as one
of the proponents of the great man view
of history that history is nothing but
the story of a series of great men who
changed the direction in which humanity
travels so what we're going to do in
this video is think about whether it
really is all about a great man or were
there other things that were in the
context of the time and space in which
these things occur this is what the
world looked like in the year 600
Muhammad starts spreading his
revelations in 610 and so you can see on
this map there's two major powers the
Byzantines which is the eastern Roman
Empire the vest
is of the Roman Empire and you also have
the Sassanid Persian Empire the
Byzantines are a Christian Empire and
the sassanids are Zoroastrian and
Muhammad is from the Quraysh tribe which
is in charge of Mecca which is
considered a pilgrimage site for the
various tribes of Arabia but you can see
that Arabia is fragmented and this
doesn't even do justice to how
fragmented it was but if you
fast-forward 200 years you see a major
change and in fact you wouldn't even
have to go all the way to 800 even by
the early 8th century you see that Islam
has spread from the Iberian Peninsula
all the way to the Indus and most of
this as mentioned happens within a
hundred years after Muhammad's death but
let's ask our central question why did
Islam emerge so rapidly where and when
it did and there's no clear right or
wrong answer here it's all going to be
conjecture but that's what's fun about
history we can think about what we think
we know and then we can debate and think
about are there some patterns here that
we see over and over in history well
what's the context so we know for a fact
that Arabia was fragmented that the law
of the land in Arabia was tribal and
tribal justice and this is the world
that Muhammad grew up in the various
tribes often worshipping different gods
we also know at this time that Muhammad
had exposure to other religions some of
which had penetrated the various tribes
of Arabia most notably you have
Christianity and Muhammad's wife's
cousin was in fact a Christian and you
also have Judaism these two clearly
being related religions Christianity
coming out of a Jewish tradition we also
know that the two great empires here the
Byzantines and Persian empires are in
constant conflict and in fact the Arabs
and many in the Middle East are the
pawns in that conflict and so you have
the Byzantines versus the Persians
with the possibility of those living in
their lands might not have been happy
with either there's also the sense that
we're at the very beginning of a long
decline for the Byzantine Empire
so one thesis could be that Mohammed was
able to bring many of the ideas of
Christianity and Judaism but these ideas
helped to unify a fragmented Arab people
and not only did it unify them but it
gave them the energy that you can have
through religious zeal and that energy
is what allowed them not only to unify
in Arabia and they're able to unify most
of Arabia by the time of Muhammad's
death but within a hundred years of his
death they're able to take over the
entire Sassanid Empire and make major
inroads into the Byzantine Empire and so
one argument might be and I encourage
you to argue with me that they were
unified they had this missionary zeal
which perhaps was only seen in
Christianity before Islam and they were
able to take advantage of conflict and
discontent between the Byzantines and
Persians in order to spread now another
question is do we see any patterns here
are there any other examples in history
of this happening well the most
comparable religion is Christianity
which is today larger than Islam but
Christianity you have a long period
between Jesus who is the central figure
of Christianity who is the underlying
spiritual figure and when Christianity
really spreads and really becomes an
empire and that really starts with
Constantine roughly 300 years after the
time of Jesus what's interesting about
the example in this video the example of
Islam in terms of the religion Mohammed
plays a little bit of both of these
roles he is a spiritual figure he has
revelations but he is also the founder
of an empire he also
governs he is also a military and
political figure and so perhaps for the
first time in history on this scale you
have the combination of religious zeal
of spiritual belief of faith combined
with governance combined with the desire
to create an empire in terms of empire
the only thing that might be comparable
in terms of the vastness and the speed
in which it happens is the Mongol Empire
the Mongols are an example of people who
are fragmented initially tribal unified
by jenga's Khan and through that
unification were able to spread
incredibly rapidly and take on some long
historic and possibly declining empires
so I'll leave you there it's a
fascinating question that historians
debate to this day Aslam started awfully
fast and spread awfully fast why did
this happen was it some unique
characteristics of Mohammed was it some
unique characteristics of the religion
or as Thomas Carlyle alludes to maybe
this whole region was just waiting for
something like this something to unify
the tribes of Arabia and take on the
decaying Byzantine and sassanid empires